la alta comisionada ha pedido a china
que revise su política antiterrorista
para evitar que caiga en la
arbitrariedad y en la discriminación y
que pueda cumplir así con los estándares
internacionales de derechos humanos
también ha pedido a china que informe a
la comunidad uigur en el exilio del
paradero de los familiares con los que
han perdido el contacto son las críticas
más afiladas después del viaje por
xinjiang de bachelet y va a ser
improbable que vayan a contentar a las
organizaciones de derechos humanos que
temían que este viaje pudiera ser
utilizado por china para blanquear sus
desmanes con los seguros base le ha
asegurado que a pesar de la burbuja
innegociable en tiempos de coronavirus
ha disfrutado de un viaje abierto y
transparente que ha podido hablar con
figuras al margen de las autoridades y
que ha podido visitar un centro de
reeducación
el viaje coincide con la publicación en
la prensa internacional de fotos de ures
que habrían sido forzados a ingresar en
estos centros esta red fue ideada por
china para combatir el radicalismo
islámico y habría sido ya desmantelada
eso es al menos lo que las autoridades
a bachelet